[Musique]
à nous deux maintenant tel un Rastignac
des temps modernes ce cévenol pure
souche a décidé d'enivrer Paris Francis
gourdin est depuis deux ans monologue
distingué et officiel du Clos Montmartre
[Musique]
le Clos Montmartre le seul vignoble de
la capitale un terrain mythique de 1559
mètres carrés situés au pied du
sacré-cœur
[Musique]
à la qualité magnifique c'est
extrêmement mûr très mûr je crois que
c'est la première année que c'est aussi
pourtant vous aviez l'air soucieux en
rentrant
oui bien sûr parce qu'il a fait des
intempéries enfin il a fait quelques
grosses pluies ces jours derniers mais
finalement donc ça s'annonce très bien
ce sera je pense d'excellente qualité
originaire de Durfort dans le Gard
Francis est tombé naturellement amoureux
de ce couteau unique un vignoble sauvé
par miracle en 1933 de la pitié vorace
des promoteurs immobiliers c'est un
endroit magnifique c'est quand même un
des deux endroits des derniers endroits
tranquilles de Paris l'oeil de Francis
pétille de reconnaissance à la veille
des vendanges il profite une dernière
fois d'une promenade en solitaire plutôt
rare dans ce lieu hautement touristique
demain matin il y aura ici au mètre
carré plus de journalistes que de raisin
métro boulot coteaux avec Francis
gourdin le surréalisme des situations
n'est jamais très loin
[Musique]
il est certainement le seul œnologue au
monde à prendre le métro pour aller
vendanger
prenez nos langues
à Paris
c'est la plus belle récompense qui
puisse exister Francis parle surtout
pour lui sachez que tous ces confrères
ont refusé le défi du Clos Montmartre
réputé imbuvable notre gardois plane
bien au-dessus du sacré-cœur pour ne pas
croire au miracle
son rêve faire du bon et du vrai rouge
en plein cœur de Paris et c'est ce jeudi
4 octobre 96 que tout se décide
alors comment vas-tu
[Musique]
la cantinière de montre et au boulot
et ça c'est le vrai plaisir
ça commence par la cueillette
ça se continue bien sûr après par la
vinification mais moi je trouve que de
participer à la cueillette pour moi
c'est absolument indispensable parce
qu'on évalue bien la qualité de la
vendange la qualité de la matière
première et de cette façon là on peut
agir en conséquence ensuite pour la
vinification donc ah oui oui moi je mets
systématiquement la main à la pâte et je
veux voir danger
comme résoudre une équation à plusieurs
inconnus la première est de taille sur
les 1762 pieds de vignes avant danger il
y a des dizaines de cépages différents
les mariés est un tour de force
c'est un véritable conservatoire la
vigne c'est un conservatoire des cépages
de France puisqu'à diverses époques
toutes les confréries ont planté donc
des cépages de leur région donc il y a
des cépages un peu de toutes les régions
de France autre difficulté le terrain
lui-même il est exposé plein nord à la
merci des pigeons et de la pollution il
en faut plus pour démonter le Francis et
la liste n'est pas finie l'entretien par
exemple est effectué par les
sympathiques jardiniers de la Ville de
Paris la mairie du 18e étant
propriétaire du vignoble et
manifestement la vigne n'est pas la
spécialité de ces tickets parisiens à
l'accent pas très chantant
on s'est fatigué un peu pour faire
pousser un peu le raisin quoi et bon bah
ouais c'est bien quoi
de voir ce qu'on récolte combien de
kilos ça fait plaisir quoi
ça va faire comme les autres années je
crois qu'on sera pas en dessous du quota
peut-être un peu plus passer des points
et variétés ça c'est une autre variété
que celle-là par exemple donc celle là
ça donne un peu plus que celle-là mais
en principe tous tes tout est bon là il
y a du pinot noir du diamètre du
chasselet
d'autre mais bon
je connais à peu près quelques notions
pas plus l'autre impératif à gérer
l'envahissement médiatique même la télé
japonaise s'est déplacée pour l'occasion
les jardiniers perdent beaucoup de temps
à faire les jolis coeurs pour les photos
souvenirs le célèbreologue également il
enchaîne les interviews plutôt que les
tours de bras
le cru 96 se présente très très bien et
je souhaite qu'une chose c'est qu'il est
la même qualité sinon supérieur au cru
95 que vous avez là
[Musique]
le caveau du Clos Montmartre se cache
dans le sous-sol de la mairie du 18e le
raisin y est toujours précis à l'aide de
moyens archaïques Emmanuel mais en deux
ans notre œnologue a changé certaines
mauvaises habitudes pour revenir au
Beaba de toupie culculteur
en vinifiez pas en rouge tout simplement
c'est une vinification en rosée ou en
blanc et qui donnait quelque chose de
d'assez difficilement buvable et pour
rendre hommage au travail de Francis un
simple coup d'oeil suffit à gauche la
cuvée 94 est encore d'une couleur
indéfinissable en revanche à droite la
cuvée 95 son premier bébé est d'une
belle robe rouge
son travail c'est bien tu sais il faut
faire sans voix qui fait ça avec amour
et c'est la chose la principale tu vois
c'est lui quoi tu retrouves sa
personnalité dans ce qu'il fait et ça
c'est bon
en véritable alchimiste monologue a su
défier les lois de la rationalité avec
des méthodes simples le clomontre est
désormais buvable vu le prix de la
bouteille s'est enfin justice 200 francs
minimum le 2 ml vendu au profit des
œuvres sociales du 18e Francis n'est
d'ailleurs pas peu fier de cette
réussite personnelle j'ai l'impression
de refaire un petit peu le vin de mon
enfant dans cette ligne miniature assez
difficile par ailleurs parce que bon
c'est pas parce que c'est en petite
quantité que c'est facile mais c'est un
vrai plaisir j'y mets toute ma fougue
toute mon énergie toute ma bonne volonté
et j'essaie d'améliorer aussi la qualité
de ce vin
c'est super c'est bon
[Musique]
mis à part les Japonais les amis de
bonne volonté peu de connaisseurs
s'intéressent vraiment au Clos
Montmartre la preuve le soir même à la
Tour Eiffel lors d'une vente aux
enchères exceptionnelles en duplex avec
New York Francis est comme un petit
garçon sauva figure dans une liste
prestigieuse au côté d'un lafit
Rothschild 1846 partie ce soir-là à 2000
[Applaudissements]
tout à fait exceptionnel ils sont ceux
de mon vin symboliquement maître tageon
l'un des commissaires priseurs les plus
réputés de Paris proposaient 5 coffrets
composés de deux bouteilles plus une
carafe d'un cristallier français célèbre
ça vaut la peine d'être au goûter à New
York à 1500 francs New York n'a pas
voulu et les lots sont partis au prix du
cristal ils ont des collectionneurs mais
le problème c'est surtout qui croit
encore que le vin est pas buvable
patience Francis Le clomonmartre va
devoir attendre le troisième millénaire
pour briller enfin de mille feux
[Musique]